attention all you Babel heads in England
Scotland Ireland Hollywood babble-on is
coming to you yes it's been years but
we're coming back because we missed you
we're kicking off our big tour in May
with Ireland
if you're near Dublin you got to come
out and see us its Babel go brah
in Dublin Ireland on Thursday May 9th at
the vicar street then Birmingham England
is up next
on Saturday May 11th at Symphony Hall
then we move on to Manchester
we're playing the o2 Apollo there on May
12th and then it's on to Edinburgh we're
gonna see you guys in Scotland at uh
sure hall there on May 14th and then we
wrap up the whole thing in London
Wednesday May 15th we're gonna have a
great show in London we had a great time
there last time and we're looking to
come back and do the same so if you are
in Ireland if you are in England if you
are in Scotland here is your chance to
see Hollywood babble-on live me and
Kevin Smith in your hometown
where do you get you tickets well where
you get your tickets for all things smog
Co you go to see smog dot-com see smog
calm s EE s mo D and then go down find
the show near you click on the tickets
and info and then get your tickets we
want to see you next in May when we come
to England Scotland and Ireland we'll
see you there ok spider-man far from
home is coming like just as we're all oh
post endgame orgasmic now suddenly we're
gonna check in on the Marvel Cinematic
Universe in a spoilers post stark world
ok
the the trailer for spider-man far from
home this is the second trailer features
more Mysterio I'm told and features some
stuff that will tie directly into the
events of infinity Wars so I have not
infinity where endgame if anywhere in
endgame
so without further ado let's dive in
once again Tom Holland my favorite
cinematic spider-man he just gets it man
a man is I love the fact that he did a
Queen's accent makes sense how come
nobody ever did in New York accent for
Peter Parker before it so smart love his
is dynamic of course that he had with
Robert Downey jr. I love the spider-man
stark dynamic the father-son mentor kind
of thing and so we're about to see what
happens when spider-man don't have his
mentor no more I'm Peter Parker don't
get to hang out with Peter starker the
the events of endgame I was wondering
are they gonna have an effect we do a
podcast called fat man beyond me and
Mark Barnard and Mark Barnard and was
saying like oh maybe this takes place
before endgame um you know and I was
like I hope not I guess want to move
forward you know I happened to flash
backs and if you want to jump through
time and stuff but do a whole story post
snap and post Reese nap or T snap the
you know the strange
forward momentum ever forward so I hope
this trailer is set post snap I love
Mark Barnard and he's and usually I love
when he improves a movie but I hope he's
not right about that we're gonna find
out together for call this chatter let's
dive in man now mind you we've seen what
Mysterio looks like in the first trailer
so I'm not gonna have the same sense of
ooh but maybe there's new footage in
this trailer maybe we get to learn a bit
more about Mysterio's mission let us
watch shall we I I've got it started
right where the trailer begins not there
was a there was a Tom Holland intro
thing and then I stopped it right after
that so this is just when the trailer
begins line it up here we go everywhere
I go I'm still in the Seuss ooh
oh he's saying this be sad about
that I think to me he's got cry eyes if
he didn't know that you were gonna be
here after he was gone
[Music]
I love the iron spider suit and they
keep using the last Wow directly ties in
with the iron spider seat and I love
that nature's calling fabs is a big
spark man because if you don't started
all this
you sent nick fury to voicemail I gotta
go you do not we're just talking about
the trip seen this you're a very
difficult person to contact spider-man
ah you seen that dude but still now it
makes sense this mr. bet you world's
Beck is finger just not out a snap to
our home in our dimension I was just
about to say multiversal Maria hello
holy [ __ ] did you see them shaking hands
black suit [ __ ] please you've been to
space they said [ __ ] is mr. Peter
[ __ ] Mysterio look at [ __ ] they're
hanging out and talking they can't be
friends no I mean it's kind of obvious
you may not be ready but this is my
responsibility
oh that bubble helmet god damn it that
must mean will die
take John Horace more material you want
to step up
[Music]
come on man let's line that up again and
get ready for another roll um my god
that's fantastic all right let me let me
let me do a brief a debrief it seems
like well they introduced Nick Fury
introduces Quentin back to Peter Parker
Mysterio spider-man and says he's from
the snap ripped a hole and created a
multiverse lot to unpack I don't doubt
that that's true that you know cuz the
snap and holes in time that's how we're
gonna get the Fantastic Four and the
x-men in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
but I know Quentin Beck I've written for
Quentin Beck his voice Quentin Beck's a
liar he's an actor something tells me
he's not from another world I don't
think he is from some other place I
think he's worth [ __ ] and there's no
way that they they're just friends he's
he's got to be the [ __ ] bad guy at
his pitch but oh my god what a cool
approach and holy [ __ ] right at the top
of the trailer they're like spoilers
spoilers spoilers ready spoilers but at
the top of the trailer like Tony Stark
is [ __ ] dead man like we haven't had
that much time to sit with it and
[ __ ] live with it now they're putting
out another movie to tell us it's
official kids he's gone
deal with it your surrogate father is
[ __ ] dead what are you gonna do with
the rest of your lives man and that's us
I mean there's a bit of that going on in
the trailer with spider-man as well
unhappy
that [ __ ] bubble helmet man looks
phenomenal to fishbowl oh oh I love that
we live in a world man where Mysterio
has the fishbowl helmet and I love that
he looks like Jake Gyllenhaal under it
[ __ ] he looks good man all right let's
try and think of it as any big swig I
mean that seems to be the big sweeping
changes mayor MJ saying you're
spider-man I wonder if that's a mislead
or if that's just good boy they just
[ __ ] dumped that in the trailer I'm
ready for this I like this the last guy
that the guy who did this last time I
love that [ __ ] spider-man homecoming
I know I'm gonna love this
I love that they're tied in but the idea
of a multiverse kids means that any
minute now
we might get Miles Morales and they
mentioned Miles Morales and you know
spider-man of homecoming so he exists in
that world so you don't even need a
multiverse a hole in the universe to get
to Miles Morales Miles Morales exists
well I mean you know Fowler does so
anyway let's [ __ ] dive back in like
this good [ __ ] man
everywhere I go I see his face oh that's
awesome
my imagination I want to live in a world
with Ironman ERISA two murals all over
the [ __ ] walls I don't think Tony
would have done what he did cry odds
here partners you're gonna be here after
school breaks my heart
yeah good job chips yeah Jeff Jeff Jeff
shop
they're gonna be in exile Amanda well no
I don't have time
too busy doing your jobs
looks real world looks like it actually
exists as opposed to NSF the end game
because if you don't talk you set Nick
Fury to voicemail I gotta go you do not
go we're just talking about the trip
you're a very difficult person to
contact in spite of me
Avengers mr. 4.0 it was one like you on
my world
your worlds BIC is from Earth just not
house a snap to our home in our
dimension I believe this I believe
there's no job to do you're coming with
a big Clinton Beckett from it
[Music]
he's a liar don't believe it
Thor and Jeb Marty marvel off world none
about [ __ ] please you've been to space
[Music]
a guy who wrote mysterion like this is
eNOS
Thank You rose woman my journal runs
away you may not be ready but this is my
responsibility
oh look at that [ __ ] I love this world
my friends eating hoagies next Iron Man
look at a man all that [ __ ] glorious
green Mysterio look like he's vapor this
shots fantastic
the guys dragged cops or [ __ ] man
what bro
July 2nd man there's my independence
make mine Marvel [ __ ] this is damn good
and damn exciting stuff there's a damned
exciting stuff
what up what do I give it my second
viewing what are those elemental things
man my guys got to be Mysterio created
as we thought from the last trailer but
I think it's interesting that the angle
they're gonna take is like to team them
up and that you know the world needs an
Iron Man and that spider-man might have
to step up to be that guy that's it's
great storytelling kids it continues
thwip thwip I'm flipping shooting webs
all over the [ __ ] place man this
movie looks dope
can't wait just when like avengers
endgame gonna be coming out streaming
you know we could watch it at home we'll
be able to dive and just spider-man far
from home I hope they keep this schedule
like two movies a year maybe three
whatever until the dad died and I hope I
don't die for a long [ __ ] time so I
get to see a lot more Marvel movies but
keep this up and like is this you know
some people are like Christmas and
Easter my two favorite times here when
they released these movies that's my two
favorite times a year so I love this
[ __ ] I'm in the bag check it out man
it's online spider-man far from home for
Marvel Studios and the good folks at
Sony man Sony who has an Oscar for
[ __ ] spider-man at this point four
into the spider-verse
man they're killing it with the help of
Marvel as well all right there it is
folks more when there's more bike
you